CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
This week, we're
talking about BigQuery,
anomaly detection, and data
engineering.
I'm Cassie Kozyrkov, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
BigQuery already lets
you analyze petabytes
of data at lightning speed.
And it just got even
better with the addition
of a bunch of cool new
features, including
new user-defined functions,
faster reporting capabilities,
increased concurrency
limits, and new functions
for encryption and GIS.
The bottom line, helping you get
more out of your data faster.
See the article for
tutorials and demo links.
Last year, we
announced BigQuery ML,
bringing supervised
machine learning
to your multi-petabyte data set.
And now, we've
added unsupervised
learning capabilities, too.
In this blog post,
you'll learn how
to train a machine learning
model to catch surprises
in your data, all without having
to write a single line of code
outside of BigQuery SQL.
Check out the full story.
And while we're on
the topic of SQL,
let's talk about
database migration.
If you're keen to migrate
your MySQL database to Cloud
SQL, our fully-managed
database service designed
to take care of that
heavy lifting for you,
you might want to check out
this new hands-on tutorial
for setting up your
automated migration workflow.
For the data
engineers among you,
we're excited to announce a
professional Data Engineer
Certification exam to put that
spotlight on your expertise.
Go earn your certificate
today and get noticed faster
for high-demand roles.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.